to one day I had a chat with Grant
Cardone about branding and it reminded
me that all the lessons that I learned
in business applied to all this organic
stuff and so I was on this call with him
and I have the full video on my YouTube
channel if you want to check it out he
was like bro
I'm not even gonna try uh he was like
bro pull up your Instagram and I was
like okay he's like pull up my Instagram
he's like I got 10 times the content is
you 10 times he's like bro it's volume
bro volume I was like that's deep
um and so I was like you know I should
probably do more uh which is a lesson
that I have learned over and over and
over again in business so many times
we're doing the right stuff we're just
doing way way too little of it and so
things were going smoothly